next on book TV joshua cooper rama
co-ceo of Kissinger associates talks
about his latest book the seventh sense
with authors Malcolm Gladwell and Jacob
Weisberg
[Music]
hello hi thank you everybody for coming
this is great
you know as a writer for most of the
last few months I've been getting up
every morning saying to my wife what if
nobody reads the book and I woke up this
morning said well nobody come so it's
very nice to be able to come out tonight
and I know that some of you are here to
talk about the book but the realities
were very fortunate to have with us like
two friends of mine who I think will be
more interesting and probably more
fascinating than many of you Jacob
Weisberg who many of you may know is the
chairman and CEO of the slate group a
longtime journalist has recently
published a book on Ronald Reagan that I
can't recommend highly enough
particularly in today's political
environment and Malcolm Gladwell
everybody knows a writer for The New
Yorker and numerous very successful very
insightful non-fiction bestsellers so
we're going to talk a little bit tonight
about my new book the seventh sense and
one of the things that probably also
pretty quickly we get into conversation
is that one of the big ideas in the
seventh sense is that there's just so
many questions to answer that this model
of kind of us talking to you is not
entirely the right model so we'll do
that but we also really want to open up
to questions and debate and I hope
people will will talk about the ideas
that are interesting so with that we'll
plunge and I think we just have a little
conversation up here Jake is going to
talk to me and and then we're all going
to talk and then we'll open up the
questions so again thanks for coming
it's great to see so many people here
it's very nice
I was going to say welcome NYU graduates
I think I know you were probably tempted
to go out and celebrate after graduation
but I think coming here getting a start
on your career is instead of figuring
out what this thing all about it's a
good way - a good way to launch your
post-collegiate
you will outperform the people who are
out drinking right now I think as some
as the least thing we're not as I was
going to say the least famous person
here I decided I should probably be the
moderator so I'm going to try to just
sort of direct the conversation a little
bit at least to get started
and I wanted to started off just by
asking Josh to explain a little bit of
what he's trying to do in the book and
and how he got interested in and so on
and and just to get started Josh what is
the seven cents so uh you know the the
historical context of seven cents is
I'll get to in a second I mean seven
cents is really this this feeling this
instinct for the way in which we're a
meshed in all of these networks now
which fundamentally changed things and
when you look around the world today and
you see you know the most expensive war
on terrorism in human history
not succeeding and maybe producing more
terrorists an economic policy that was
designed to try to help the middle class
and stabilize the economy that appears
to be kind of accelerating in fragility
and certainly fragility and certainly
causing problems of things like
deflation if you look at the political
environment there all these things
happening there's sort of unexpected and
my idea was to really kind of see could
I roll up my sleeves understand what was
what was driving that I came at it from
kind of a couple of different
perspectives so one was and a very
interesting experience back when you and
I are first getting to know each other
back in the 90s which is I I had briefly
run an internet startup company that
failed so that I had got that experience
under my belt and in the process of
shutting it down I got a phone call from
this guy I'd never heard of before named
Mike Moritz this was in the mid 1990s
and Mike said look you don't know me I
used to be a journalist of time and I've
now moved into the venture capital
business would you mind getting on a
plane and coming out to Silicon Valley
because I really think there's a company
you ought to think about joining I just
shut this company down and I was about
to join time as a senior editor and I
said why not I'll go out so I fly out
and Mike
this is my first encounter in venture
capital so I was not prepared for what I
got but future encounters with venture
capitalists would not be that dissimilar
showed up at San Francisco Airport in
his convertible Mercedes picked me up
and took me down to this warehouse where
there were these three guys sitting
around starting a company and I and said
look this is really where you ought to
work and I was like do I do this or do I
go to Time magazine which seemed like
you know that really was the icon of
every possible dream you could you could
have in journalism so I looked at the
company I said you know the opportunity
to be employing number four the company
called Yahoo that thing's not going
anywhere what kind of name is that for a
company and I very happily got on an
airplane and flew back to New York City
thinking like who I think goodness I
missed that one I have this great
stability of Time magazine that's not
going anywhere right so once you make an
eight hundred million dollar mistake
like that you even if your vision is not
to have eight hundred million dollars
you sort of say to yourself what was
that I kind of missed at this moment and
it was clear to me sir as I moved
through things over the years that there
was this dynamic in the system this
possibility of the creation of
incredible new basin's of prosperity of
informational ideas that came nearly
just from connection itself and so I
think you know part of it is part of
where the seven cents came from was the
sense of you know geez I wish I'd had it
back then but part of it also was the
sense it's as you look around the world
so many businesses I'm starting to the
business that were in and we lived in
which is this kind of disturbance in
business are being disrupted by these
huge forces what I saw when I left
journalism you know 10 or 12 years ago
and went into the advisory business and
moved to China was that these forces are
really working out all over society that
the things that have happened
unfortunately design magazine are
happening to military affairs they're
happening in economics and all of our
old ideas are being kind of upturned and
so my question was was there some way
that I could really get to the root of
understandings we all know the kind of
basic idea which is that connection
changes the nature of an object a
connected phone a connected journalist
it's just different than one that's
connected economy than one that's not
connected what I wanted to try to do in
the book is figure out what what was
underneath that and was there a certain
sensibility behind that what I saw it
was there were people you know Travis
kalanick looks at a car and sees
something different that produces uber
then when I look
and I just see a car there and so the
sentence really is that story of that
instinct that's there it's what I
discovered of course let's look it's a
learn about instinct this is something
you can understand it is something that
is that is usable you know because
people all around us have it but it does
often kind of challenge traditional ways
of thinking but just to be very
literal-minded about it I mean we know
what the five senses are and the sixth
sense is a sense of history right that's
that's right was the description of
Napoleon did he enter Nietzsche yeah but
need to use it to describe Nietzsche's
view was that in the Industrial
Revolution Nietzsche was like look this
is so crazy
that my five senses are not enough and
we're all going to go crazy which
Nietzsche did anyhow but he said you
know we need an additional sense in that
sense of a sense of history that if you
what he called the sixth sense this idea
that if you sort of had a sense of where
this change was on the ebb and flow of
human history it would give you
something to grab on to and so the idea
of the seventh sense is I think we still
need the five senses we need the sixth
sense but I think we also need a sense
of what does it mean to be a mesh how
does that change things so it's this
understanding of networks and when you
know Silicon Valley people sort of say
they divided the world into people who
get it and people who don't get it the
people who get it they're talking about
people who have this understanding of
how connection changes the nature of
business changes the nature of politics
changes the nature of everything and
people who can take advantage of that
yeah and I think that's a piece of I
think what I've tried to do in the book
is say that that ability to understand
network systems is a piece of it but
might be the seventh sense actually also
incorporates a different element which
is that it's not enough simply to
understand the network's you've got to
understand the world into which they're
moving and so I think I almost have a
sense of data kind of the world one way
to look at is sort of on the one hand
you've got a group of people who have a
tremendous amount of power in economics
and politics and traditional media who
don't really understand how networks
work and in the process of trying to
solve problems often make them worse and
then you have a group people understand
networks really really well and they
tend to be younger they tend to sit at
the heart of these companies where you
can make the case the control of you
know the Google algorithm of the
Facebook algorithm those are the most
powerful handles of ever been assembled
in human history in a way and that group
I talked about in the book and I spend
time with doesn't necessarily understand
the law
social constructs of the ideas of you
know whether it's the classical
philosophical ideas or the ideas about
what makes an economy or society
function and so the rest of us are sort
of stuck in the middle and so I think
the cultivation the seventh sense maybe
we can talk later about the issues
around artificial intelligence we're not
going to beat the machines the machines
are phenomenal the idea isn't that we
should learn more about computers to
save ourselves it's that we have to
understand both the networks and the
kind of history and ideas that surround
them and that really offer a path
forward but often this manifests itself
and you tell these stories in a reversal
of an existing power dynamic or a kind
of asymmetry in the dynamic I mean Isis
you described as assertive $0.07
phenomenon you know Donald Trump with
just his little old little old donald
donald trump with his twitter account
versus the republican establishment and
the thing that that everyone expects
doesn't happen because some $0.07
person or organization shows up and and
uses it differently yeah that the
network's fundamentally permit you they
change the way in which these forces
behave and so when somebody looked at
isis and thought these are just a bunch
of you know 15 Yahoo's with trucks what
they discover actually is that when
you're part of a connected system that
ability to make these videos these
horrible you know videos of 12 people
being beheaded has a kind of viral power
that traditional power structures have a
very hard time competing with I'm going
to stick Malcolm on you in a second but
I just what sort of one more question I
was thinking about reading the book do
these people who are the beneficiaries
of the phenomenon are they people who
understand it or they just beneficiaries
of it I mean does Donald Trump
understand networks understand what
you're talking about intuitively or is
it just somehow he's harnessed it and
latched on to it I mean I think it is
maybe a little bit of both right I mean
I think there is this intuitive sense
some people have of how the networks
work and then I think there's just the
there are many things one of the things
about networks is they're very contagion
prone in fact we build them to be
contagion prone right because we want
them to be efficient I think one of
points I make in the book is that the
network's evolve in ways that suit what
the network's want and what they want is
to be faster they want to be connected
all the time they want to be super
efficient and so we're bill
systems that are are hyper contagious
without necessarily the kind of
foundational belief under structure of
saying well what are you doing in a very
contagious system this is really germane
in the you know for better or worse in
this kind of world of foreign policy and
security because the the larger
historical narrative against which all
this takes place is when power shifts
dramatically when the way power is
structured inside system shifts
dramatically that creates these
incredible disruptions so in the book I
make this comparison between the
Enlightenment in the Industrial
Revolution which over a you know three
hundred year period really starting with
the Reformation wiped out many of the
sacred European institutions which is
architected for a different power
structure for a different idea of who
should be in charge and if it's right
now if you look around the world today
there are very few institutions that we
trust more than we trusted you know ten
years ago I mean almost everything has
kind of declined and that's a worrisome
signs questions I serve on what basis do
you build build this kind of new order
um
so Malcolm I thought I had reading this
book was oh my god David and Goliath
your most recent book is about a
symmetries that work out in surprising
ways and Wow why there are cases in
which underdogs are successful how does
reading Josh's book how does your theory
match up with his theory Oh
until we didn't prepare for this he's
completely flummoxed about my question
and thought about that Mike went on I
mean I suppose then the network is a lot
of what Josh is talking about is a
deceptive power of networks that you
because we have a tendency to focus on a
component of a network we miss the the
kind of hidden power that comes from the
connectivity so in essence it does it's
a it is a version of a David and Goliath
argument which is that David is actually
much stronger than he appears
although I'm actually more what I'm more
into it what I was more interested in
after reading the book was the downside
of networks you know what they I I wish
you could I'd love for you to explain a
little bit more Josh what they can't do
and so that if the opposite of a network
is a hierarchy
what sort of situations are networks
best optimized for and what situations
are hierarchies most appropriate floor
yeah and I think that's another question
which is related that which is and I
think is that you know we're so early in
this process of figuring out what
network power means the other question
is like why do certain networks
structure themselves in certain ways and
can we predict in advance which network
structures are likely to emerge so one
of the classic models of network
structures is so-called winner-take-all
Network structures just a we have in the
world I think nine platforms that have
more than a billion users on the
Facebook Google Microsoft Office
Microsoft Windows on YouTube and what's
interesting is these systems as we all
know have this winner-take-all effect
which is right the more people use
Facebook the more people need to use
Facebook so then more people use
Facebook and that it creates these
natural monopolies which were not really
necessarily used to dealing with the
economic structures of those are
actually it's very cheap for Facebook to
add every additional user so they just
get more and more profitable as time
goes on and it has the effect of
concentrating a huge amount of power in
the hands of very very few people so and
not with power I mean if you look at the
the the deal around whatsapp which was I
think a nineteen billion dollar deal at
half the user base today it's almost a
billion dollars per employee at that
company so one of the questions is why
does certain topologies network so
Network you know spaces are defined by
topologies one of the fruits that just
maybe just slow down yes plane without a
little hour for those who've forgotten
what it de passe right so a topology the
idea of a topology is that it comes from
mathematics and computer network theory
is that they're these sort of invisible
like there's a geography that you can
see right there's a geography of New
York City there's a geography of Europe
that shaped all kinds of decisions where
the rivers ran where the mountains were
where the coast lines were and for most
of human history the thing that mattered
the most was geography if you were
fighting a war you wanted to control the
coast so you wanted to control the
airspace you wanted to control the
mountain passes
well topologies are things that emerge
as a result purely of connectivity so
for instance the distance between st.
Petersburg and Moscow
is always 450 miles but depending on how
its connected it can take you a week to
get there it can take you a millisecond
to get there and so topologies have this
feature which is they change shape
depending on the nature of the
connection and their topologies for
currencies Facebook has a topology of
how people are connected that same is
six degrees of separation idea all kind
of a herd of us exactly all kinds of
networks have topological features and
designs and they OP tend to optimize
themselves for the design that makes the
most efficient so the interesting
question is you know are there areas so
we know for instance why the Facebook
effect works which is right the more
people use it the what's interesting is
when you look at businesses like Amazon
that at the beginning were not it wasn't
inherently clear that a merchandise
business was going to have that effect
if the more people used Amazon therefore
more people would want to use it well
why couldn't more people use Amazon and
also use Walmart and all these other
things and the great business inside of
Jeff Bezos was to figure out a way to
drive it to this topology where the more
people who use it the faster his cost
went down which allowed him to get more
people to use it and so on so the
question is it's it's also it's not easy
enough to say ok there's there's
hierarchies and topologies which is
covered or network structures which is
kind of where I was what you find is
actually they're different network
designs that serve different needs and
this is particularly interesting as the
great the great question about this when
you talk to people who are designing
these systems now is how our artificial
intelligence system is going to
distribute themselves because there's an
argument to be made that if you have
access to all of this data the smarter
the AI system gets so then it either
gets more data on itself or more people
want to use it so that they can take
advantage of it just get smarter and
smarter so part of the $0.07 which
honestly i think we're still trying to
figure out is what is what is the right
topological distribution of power and
the last thing I'll say about it the
reason that that's important is it gets
you right at the heart of these
questions of things like how does a
democratic system function the
democratic system functions based on
this premise of relatively equal
distribution of power capitalism
functions a with this idea of relatively
equal participation in the marketplace
we have regulations and all kinds of
things to deal with that what do you do
and what the system craves is actually a
very different kind of structure
but I mean I'm interested to hear you
sort of explain in into the specific
examples what's different I mean we had
we had networks and call them topologies
if you want you know in the political
structures in the 19th century I mean a
political patronage system is a network
what is the sort of difference and why
is that
vulnerable not durable in relation to
the kind of network you know President
Obama's social media network that he
leveraged in the campaign so I think
it's very important to know to say
actually networks unlock a huge
understanding of a lot of history in
fact if you look at most of the great
empires you can think of them in fact as
network systems the empires that were
built on the rivers of Asia or India
that were built on the ocean the British
Empire was nothing is not a networked
Empire just happened to be conducted by
ships instead of by by electrons and
there's a lot of very interesting work
being done now in economics and history
where you go back and analyze these
things as network systems understand the
efficiencies as part of them the biggest
change now is I take two things one is
the incredible speed at which things
happen on networks there's a famous line
of one German general about a hundred
years ago towards the end of the First
World War who said you know if this
negotiations leading up to the war had
been conducted by horseback instead of
this damn Telegraph we could have
avoided the war this Telegraph was just
so fast we didn't know what to do about
it so that acceleration of daily life is
which we all know from our daily
existence has spilled into the network
so that's the first thing is the speed
of the networks is unbelievably fast and
that one of the things when you ask
yourself what drives this movement
towards a winner-take-all system partly
that is efficiency they're much faster
if you had to look for your friends on
Facebook and Fenster and MySpace what
you would discover is that it's a very
inefficient process there was a small
team at Facebook that about three years
in when they were served at this pivot
point and Friendster was still around
figured out this is central ingredient
which is if you join Facebook and you
got seven friends in 10 days you were
likely to stay and that was the
topological insight that then led to
this huge acceleration so one is speed
is different than it
and the second things are different is
this kind of winner-take-all system in
which the intelligence of the network
the more it sees the smarter it gets and
so the better it gets so let's talk a
little bit about business and let's talk
a little bit about politics and foreign
policy ma'am youyou speak a lot to
business audiences you know you have a
leader the marketing world is very
engaged in in what you're doing do you
see and you see very different you talk
for different kinds of businesses do you
see businesses that have an
understanding of what Josh is talking
about having a differential kind of
success or picking up on your last
question are there places in the
business world where a much more
conventional hierarchical structure
still obtains or still does best
well there is that there are lots of
businesses that are in a process of
transition towards something that is a
lot more it looks a lot more like a
network and are having difficulty
understanding how to adapt to that so
for example if you think about a
hospital the traditional understanding
of a hospital is that the success of the
hospital is driven by the skill of the
doctors you have world-class surgeons
that's half the battle
but now when patients are driving
decisions and patient satisfaction is so
important your patient satisfaction may
be as much a function of how nice the
receptionist was and how nice the person
was go answer the phone as the skill of
the surgeon so that's a kind of if you
think about it now you have a you have
20 different nodes you have to worry
about as opposed to one or two now is
that know what I'm also wrestling with
is does that make up the hospital and
network I'm not sure it gives it certain
Network qualities and it changes the way
you have to make decisions if you're
running the hospital because all sudden
you now have to qualify a more a more
obvious example would be a hotel if I go
to a hotel and I go on Yelp but I give
it a lousy rating that may be because I
had a bad encounter with
one out of 600 employees right that's
that's a network biting you in the
behind if you're running the hotel right
you you may have nailed 599 of the
components of your network and you
missed out on one and then somebody
hates you for it
so I mean is that I don't know I missed
my I mean that's it it's a network
vulnerability I'm antic that's one of
the interesting things in network terms
they talk about it as expanding the
attack surface that one of the things
networks do is highly connected systems
have a larger footprint there's almost
anywhere you can hit them and you have
this incredible asymmetry which is right
one fault anywhere in the system has can
have the effect of disrupting the entire
network yeah but I would say you know
sort of picking up on that example you
know in a hospital used to be attracting
the top surgeons was most of your job or
in a hotel kind of running a great hotel
with most of your job in fact I would
think networks in a different sense that
probably more of your success depends on
what networks you tie into and what way
so you know networks for diagnosis
customer service relationships to other
Possible's institutions or in the hotel
case you know are you on the what
reservation system are you on you know
how what sort of accessibility and
service you offer that way probably
matters much more you so see if you have
a terrible hotel it's not it's not going
to you're not going to be successful
over the long term but you could have a
very good hotel and not be very
successful if you're not networked
properly well that you know this
actually raises my principle question
around the book was the is a chapter in
the book about security can essentially
computer security the security of
electronic networks and it's a very very
powerful chapter which makes you very
very afraid and it made me wonder if
security such a crucial question that
it's sufficient to make me want to opt
out of networks entirely in other words
if a bank came to me and said I'm going
to be the UH networked Bank I'm not even
going to be on the Internet if you want
to deposit money you have to show up
bank of the zone
the Stone Age and the reason I was
living or you know right now we have
this phenomenon in hospitals around this
country are being held up by they're
paying ransom to electronic thieves
right you take the medical records and
then get them back for twenty million
dollars whatever it is so why wouldn't
the hospital say you know what this was
a bank the threat of being the network
is such that we're going to opt out that
I mean I think the problem of security
is so large and underappreciated that
there are many scenarios where the
threat from being in the network is
greater than the benefits from being in
the network do you yeah I mean I think
the problem with it is that you can't
the cost visit everybody has to do this
cost-benefit analysis and the promise of
networks or I think about the hospital
case so if you go to a hospital you
would ideally like to have the doctor be
able to take your blood and immediately
run that against a database of 100
million people or a billion people and
see whether or not there's anything
interesting there so it turns out the
and as much as it'd be fun to go to the
hospital to stone age like you want to
actually have access to that information
so it turns out that the crucial
decision is exactly this one which is
how connected are you and how do you
manage the gate between inside and
outside turns out to be the essential
sort of locus of power in these systems
the other thing it's very interesting is
that I talked about this I'm in the book
how did we end up with this incredibly
insecure network system where basically
and I describe this in this in this
chapter on hacking that you cannot
secure a computer there's not a single
device in this room that we can safely
secure so one of the reasons is the
great thing that allowed the internet to
grow so quickly with this notion of
something called post Ellis principle
which is which is post all jumpers I was
one of the early founders of the
internet and he was coming from against
this sort of AT&T tradition which you
know built these giant switching centers
and said nobody gets to connect to this
unless they've been approved Postell and
you know this was the 60s and people
were sort of relaxed about things said
okay here's my principle be generous in
what you accept and be careful about
what you said but that fundamental
instinct of openness is what allowed the
Internet to grow so so much faster than
other network structures it's a mate the
reason you can flip on your phone today
and in five minutes get access to
everything in the world is because
actually this philosophical decision to
star
with a relatively open system the
problem with that is that it's a system
that is entirely open and so it's not
architected from the bottom up to be
secure and the problem with that is so
they've tried to fix this there are two
very famous innovations for this one is
known as DNS SEC which is a protocol you
can use that looks at every single bit
of information on the internet and says
where did that come from where is it
going it's sort of like a TSA for the
internet and just like the TSA it has
the effect of introducing totally
unnecessary inefficiencies into the
system and so the challenge is what we
want is more and more and more speed we
want our networks to be faster and so
there's a famous trilemma in
manufacturing which is that you can have
things any to of cheap good and fast
right so if you want to get a couch and
you'd like it to be cheap and you'd like
to get it really really quickly it's
probably not going to be very good so
you always have to balance those off so
in security there's something which is
you can be open you can be secure or
fast any any two of those so if you want
to be open and you want to be really
really fast you're not going to be
secure at all and so it's that balancing
of those things is where we are today
here's why this is a legend instead the
reason that it kind of lands is that
choice of that topology that choice of
the way we design the connect systems is
one we made and it's one we can I think
adjust to and I think one of a fishin
questions when you talk to people
thinking about the next generation of
the internet they're people thinking
about that is how do you solve the
security problem as a first concern for
network design yeah because that you
know that the so when you present it
that way and and you we take it for
granted that fast has to be one of the
three and that we also celebrate
networks because of their speed when we
make this decision what if I don't need
networks to be fast it strikes me that
much of the network relationships in my
life and in the economy of the whole are
needlessly fast why does you know Google
doesn't actually have to get back to me
in a fraction of a second I mean it's
just something I'm used to it now but
you know when I had a dial-up you know
that the same result a little slower and
if you said Malcolm I'm going to make
I'm going to I'm going to increase the
amount of time that Google takes
respond to you or your bank does a go
online citibank citibank is going to get
back to you in five minutes now now if
that was my expectation i could actually
and he told me that that would triple
the security i would take that deal in a
heartbeat yeah well but people crave I
mean what everything speed has become
the ultimate commodity of competition in
the market and so but why does Amazon
need to deliver something in two hours
to you as opposed to waiting but it is
it is people crave I mean you know you
have a little bit siege I should you say
people crave people crave that because
they're not properly pricing security if
they price security properly people
wouldn't crave it anymore
if you explain to me once you if you
explain to every consumer not a single
device here one is secure what would you
pay to make it secure then they might
have a very different attitude about
speed yeah well and one of the great
technological issues is philosophically
it shouldn't be a choice that you
actually there's a moment at which you
can design the system we're forced into
that because of the way that the system
is designed I think one of the reasons
that this is a that I kind of why do I
feel is an important book to write is
we're making decisions about how we
design systems now that are going to
endure for for decades to some degree in
terms of how they're architected and so
the decision have a relatively open
system which had a huge impact on the
spread of the internet now now induces a
whole other set of cost and so the
question is how do you redesign the
system so just one quick thing on the
security thing most people think what
the security of the fix or security is
going to be is AI that essentially you
will have artificial intelligence
machines that are serving as security
guards you might think of it this way on
the internet and that are incredibly
effective because they're talking to
themselves in their own networks and
that the solution is not that we take
the existing tcp/ip backbone of the
internet and load that up with a bunch
of TSA officers but instead is build an
entirely new approach to that but your
fundamental point which by the way
somebody you know likes to sit and read
paper books I share is we are in this
kind of speed loop of acceleration and
it has all kinds of effects but you're
both assuming that this trade-off exists
that in in the real world we're sort of
positing the possibility of security but
our fundamental experience of the last
several years has been the total lack of
security in the places where we would
most expect it I mean you know
government personnel personnel records
you know Defense Department the most
classified material the National
Security Agency and the State Department
I mean these are the things where they
weren't they didn't think they were
trading off security perimeters of face
yes um so you know and I mean if you
follow the the issue about about the
iPhone and you know Apple making
thinking it's making the choice of
security over well I mean security of
this of the system over access
accessibility the criminal justice but
in fact the FBI if you believe then
forget out a way to hack the phone if
security even possible because mine's as
good as the ones trying to design secure
systems are attacking the security I
forgotten the hilarious paradox of the
government going after Hillary Clinton
for sending classified emails on her
blackberry when blackberry is almost
certainly more secure than the US
government which is possibly the most
electronically porous we know the
government will attack we don't know for
sure that Hillary's that very exactly
they were essentially angry at her for
moving things to a more secure
environment so there was this moment
where when the Department of Defense
realized it was hack I have this in the
book they sent out this email to all of
their employees who had just received an
email saying don't open any emails
because it might be a phishing attack
second email warning them about they've
been hacked it's kind of this infinite
loop of confusion I would've liked suing
you said Josh so you said and I don't
mean to only talk about computer
security but this is a really
interesting to my mind that was the most
interesting chapter in the book because
it's the place where all many of the
strands connect and you're forced to
kind of confront so we're living in this
incredibly networked world we made a
series of choices and now we have to
subdue what the consequences of those
choices but um and the thing about
security is that why is it so difficult
for us to talk about the downside of
networks that's essentially what the
security argument is about right well
it's not of that and also to design for
it so I'll give you an example is I had
I went to a conference a couple weeks
ago on AI and ethics on artificial
intelligence and ethics and all
everybody want to talk about is this
kind of canonical AI problem which is
when the car has
go off the bridge right does it hit the
bishop or does it hit the child right
and then how are you gonna program the
AI so when it's the car is collision
over this get wrecked you planet so
depends on which go baby right so it
depends on who made the car so you know
and what you realize in that context is
that that's a that's an interesting
problem but the background problem is
actually much more interesting which is
the reason I think the computer Security
chapter is important is it's a metaphor
for all the security and network systems
that were in today we are so
fundamentally vulnerable because of the
design of these systems it's as you were
saying you know just one person anywhere
in the system can shock the entire
system so one of the things that's
happened as as a result of this constant
or connection is that the nature of what
it means to be at war what it means to
be a peace is kind of changing fairly
dramatically first of all the
distinction between the location of
combat which used to always be on the
front lines and safety in the rear areas
has gone away well anything in this room
can be weaponized by some hacker and the
second thing that's happened is that
that is then eroded any sense that okay
we're at war now or workpiece now so
when you ask yourself these questions
about AI and ethics which was the
purpose of this panel you have to start
by saying well we know that ethics are
very different at a time before than
they are at a time of peace that we sort
of that the way we approach the rule of
law and all these other sorts of things
so I think analyzing that fundamental
question what are the networks due to
our fundamental safety and it's relevant
for two reasons first of all is we know
that security from a political
perspective is one of these things that
is as it should be probably a dominant
psychological concern and causes massive
shifts when people feel insecure they
vote in certain ways they invest in
certain ways that actually tend to make
them less secure the more nationalist
and well-armed a country come becomes
the more nationalism well along with its
neighbors become so it's important from
that perspective but it's also important
because of this reason I was saying
which is we can choose how to design
these systems we can try to design them
in a way that they actually is you're
saying get rid of this false dichotomy
and make us more secure I reminded if I
once had lunch with a bunch of IT
security guys from major corporations
and I they was started talking about the
things that scare them and so I asked
for a show of hands on how many of them
had satellite radio in their cars
none of them no one told us right
they were like are you kidding me go
away with it not in a million years well
part of it all says were willing this is
another point which is a gets back to
your that why are we getting so much
speed we're so willing to trade off if
you had said to me 10 years ago I may
give you this device it's going to track
your every movement in exchange for that
I'll save you 5 minutes in traffic I was
said it's the most ridiculous trade-off
ever made but that's exactly what my
Android phone does yeah all you said oh
sorry you know god I was struck by that
quote that you had from the German
general who said can we go back to
horseback what you know when a certain
said I don't mean to sound like a
Luddite he's not wrong because what he's
saying is that when you slow down a
crucial negotiation like that you give
each side a chance to think about things
more clearly
right so there's a there's a case where
what he's essentially saying is in the
trade-off between in this case speed
thoughtfulness and whatever that third
one is I'm going to I would rather I
don't I don't mind a situation that
builds in some kind of buffer
decision-making buffer and that's
another really but it's also it's a
network design decision right so as we
think about the networks now so one of
the problems is a theory in one of the
kind of best established international
relations theories this idea of what's
known as offense defense theory and I've
had Stevens serious I've got Bob Jervis
as a professor up at Columbia really one
of his canonical ideas essentially says
that when it's very easy to attack there
are more Wars it's like when they
invented stirrups on horses people could
suddenly charged masse lines there were
more Wars when they invented walls
around fortified cities the number of
walls and your wars in Europe went down
dramatically when somebody invented
artillery that could poke through those
walls they went up very dramatically and
so one of the questions as yourself
today is what kind of world do we live
in do we live in one of offensive
dominance and beating this down
especially if you get this wrong the
example getting this wrong is world war
one world war one all the generals
thought the machine gun like that thing
is the best offensive weapon ever
developed have you seen what it does to
people no problem
war is going to be over by Christmas
turned out the machine gun was the
greatest defensive weapon in human
history and it wasn't until an actual
offensive weapon was developed in the
form of the tank at the end of the war
that the work
to an end so we're coming out of a
period the nuclear era when we didn't
have big massive Wars because it was
defense dominant right the cost of
attack was that you yourself would be
wiped out
but today the cost of attack is almost
zero you can anybody can manufacture a
little bug anybody can develop some sort
of cyber attack it's it also leads to
more and more surprise attacks it leads
to arms racing so there are all these
very dangerous conditions and what you
would like to do is step back and say
exactly what you said how do we design
some delays into this system how do we
build a network which gives us time to
react so that we don't have to need your
car way through disaster after disaster
and and those kind of decisions the ones
we can make we can make them now but
we're not I think really seeing it in
that context I mean in in the real world
we are dependent on these networks we're
not prepared to abandon them in exchange
for some sort of security that would
come from not being a part of them but
we need protection and we need
protection financial networks we need
protection national security networks
and you have in your book this idea of
gatekeeping as a sort of core idea
around foreign policy around
international relations and you talk
about the sort of gatekeeping around
this fundamental question who is inside
the gate who's outside the gate it's
when you de laboratorio sinsa particular
lis around foreign policy yeah sure I
don't I don't know if this is so I'll
say sorry I don't know if this is the
right answer but like one of the I was
trying to do in in the book was be like
okay what are the networks tell us to
some degree about how you solve these
problems and so that area I think there
a lot of mission quest like why one of
things we know about networks is we've
seen in the last 10 15 years is there
accelerants to inequality basically when
you dump a lot of money into a network
system it ends up in the hands of a
small group of people so that's an
economical problem that has to be solved
I've not not a you know thoughtful
enough person on economics have an idea
about that but I did try to think in the
foreign policy perspective what it said
so we've struggled in the last you know
decade or so really to articulate a
grand strategy for the United States
like what's our picture what the
international system on will look like
in 15 or 20 years I was curious like the
network's tell us anything about where
that's likely to go
so one of the things that you find on
these systems is there's such incredible
power in deciding who's in or out so to
take an example these winner-take-all
systems again and maybe even the best
examples it's one from cybersecurity so
in the future there will be a small
number maybe even just one cybersecurity
database that outperforms every other
database because it sees every disease
it's like a super immune system and the
more it sees the smarter gets the
stronger it gets spotting these things
called zero days which are these flaws
that are built into the code without
anybody knowing they're there these
advanced persistent threats which is
kind of the way that hackers get in the
back door and the more of these things
it sees the better it's going to get
against defending against it so all of
us in this room may say look I'd like to
sign up for this service so it protects
me to some degree those systems get more
and more powerful by a factor an
exponential factor because of something
known as Metcash law Bob Metcalfe who is
the guy who invented Ethernet discovered
which was this way to connect professors
together in Stanford in the 1970s
discovered that the more people are
connected to it the power of that system
grew exponentially not by just one
additional person right so if you have
ten people using phones or a hundred
people using phones it's not going up by
a factor of ten it's actually going up
much much more than that so the nature
of these systems then is you have a
cyber security system the more people
who use it the smarter gets the better
it is it defending itself it also turns
out that the cost of being outside of
that system grows even faster so if you
suddenly have a computer that's not
connected to this core and it's getting
better and better at defending itself
that computer has no ability to defend
itself so the decision of who is sort of
inside or outside of these gated
communities turns out to be an
incredibly important decision and to the
extent that being a part of a network
which you know is again a choice people
can make is possible is a decision the
choice to sort of be outside of it
becomes becomes very important and from
a foreign policy perspective you could
begin to imagine a world of kind of
gated communities in which people decide
who's in and who's out and that becomes
a real Nexus of power so you so
ultimately countries small countries
have to decide are they behind the
us-nato gate are they behind the China
gate are they behind the Russia gate I
mean is that how the world evolves do
you think it may because in this weed
that the fundamental activity of a
nation in the international system is
the search for security and that
question I mean the great question of
our age to some degree for nations and
for I mean even individuals which is a
sort of hospital question is you know
are you the gatekeeper you the gate kept
and if you're going to be gay kept on
what basis you're going to be gate kept
so yeah I think that's the that's the
process of the people are gonna have to
go through and understanding this is a
sort of speculative view of the world
but does that become a kind of new Cold
War and in that framework does the you
know the the offensive defensive balance
shift towards the sort of mutually
assured destruction model I mean in me
in the early days of this you know we've
had Stuxnet I mean we've been we we have
ourselves launched cyber attacks but we
very much don't like cyber attacks that
have been directed against us you know
is do we move towards a kind of global
accommodation that the idea of attacking
these networks is so terrible that we
need to have a sort of mutual tacit or
explicit agreement that we don't do that
well I mean one of the interesting is
does it the other version that question
is does it change the incentive
structure so much that people don't want
to attack it because they themselves
depend on and I don't know the answer to
that i'ma think that's what we'll we
huddle our way through if there's one
big large network and you're knotted
isn't the safest person a little person
not in the network so it's like remember
this a years ago that they were far
fewer viruses made for Apple because
Apple PCs because they were so few apple
juice because there was so few of them
so paradoxically by choosing the less
popular computer you immunized yourself
against a large portion of attack so
don't I really want to be Switzerland in
a world where there are these large
gated communities well it's what's on
the 10sec yeah what you may want to try
to develop as a completely separate
proprietary network which is hopefully
impossible to be attacked but you're
going to be competing against these
giant systems which have the ability to
study you in all sorts of levels and so
that the great paradox of this puzzle is
the shift from an industrial model where
you can either sort of opt out of it or
say you know if you're going to build 10
battleships I'm going to build 10
battleships is this problem that the guy
with the 50 battleships is going to end
up with
five thousand battleships before you
finished your your first so you can opt
out opting out is a choice and I think
there will be interesting structural
ways to do that but by doing that the
cost you pay is you don't get all of
these you would get all these benefits
email I mean I'm not just sort of
speculating here but the the whole the
whole question is how choice is the
target the reason you don't attack
Switzerland in Second World War is the
upside is small the downside is large
and you know you got a bunch of Canton's
and sleepy Zurich and you maybe lose X
number of men so I mean you know in a
from us from a a futurist Network model
I think I would feel a lot safer off by
myself well this is you know by actually
from a future Specter it also happens to
touch with one of the deepest ideas of
Taoist philosophy that the goal should
be to be a useless tree that there's
these stories about you know this tree
and all around me were these huge strong
trees and they've all been turned into
boats and floors and beds and this one
crooked tree is just kind of there
surviving so it's not a bad strategy to
deal with Lumberjacks are out but I
think all of this is you know when you
read the book it is really frightening
in places and I do think some of these
issues are so terrifying that all of us
have at least I share a little bit the
instinct of you know time time to stock
your cabin in the woods but that's not a
very fruitful it's a lot where I end up
yeah I mean III think it is there is a
lot of and by the way I mean the
historical analogy here if you do
believe this is as large as the
Enlightenment the Industrial Revolution
that triggered the biggest wars in human
history so anytime people don't give up
power easily and and that's kind of a
you know the meta historical narrative
here and we said that you know I was out
the valley last week and I was talking
to somebody who kind of has built one of
these big platform things he says you
know the thing that people on the East
Coast don't really understand very well
is that these are all positive some
games that the more people use it the
better it is actually for everybody it's
not like I use it and use it we compete
to see who gets the most out of it but
the more connection there is in the
system with the more people use Facebook
the better it is for you in a sense the
more access that you get the more
formation that you have and so if you
believe that philosophy fundamentally
and you're kind of instinctively an
optimist you hope that there's some good
attitude to get there but the the
questions it presents are just gigantic
I mean how do you what kind of political
system emerges for this order that is
right yeah well I wouldn't I mean I hate
to sort of bang this drum but on opting
out of networks but it strikes me that
the logic of technological advancement
can lead as much to the rejection of
networks as the strengthening of
networks and let me give you an example
so with the same back to my lunch with
these IT guys the other two things they
that scare them are their satellites
right a car cars great vulnerability and
two is the grid like electrical grid
terrifies them so what do they want with
the grid well what they want is an end
to the grid they think the network is
actually incredibly dangerous what they
really want is a thousand or even a
hundred thousand little mini networks so
that I can crash Columbus Ohio but I
don't crash New York City at the same
time that's what they want so having
seen and lives through a network
experience what they really want to do
is to use the next iteration of
technology to liberate us from so
indicates where that the network was
imposed without properly pricing
security the security concern is so
great they'd rather just give up on the
so that there's a and why is that
enabled that's enabled by the very same
technology that is enabling the strength
of other networks so it's this is why
when I read your book I also I felt both
terrified and also optimistic in the
sense that it doesn't seem to me that we
are logically spiraling towards ever
more complex and fraught networks
it could also in exactly the opposite
direction yeah and I think I disc gets
to this question of like how do we
choose to design the networks right
there are some that should be designed
this way the question that I find so
interesting maybe Jake I you have some
views on this because you've thought
about politics probably more than than
either of us is what did I mean we know
that what happened with the Industrial
Revolution enlightenment really starting
with the Reformation when Luther said
everybody gets their own access to God
you don't have to go through everybody
the process that came after that was
well geez man access to God I'd light
access to capital and land and voting it
was all about the liberation the
individual and so all these political
systems that were based there was a
point at which like having one guy with
10,000 serfs seemed completely
reasonable and then the next day it was
right so we saw this massive period of
revolutions in Europe as these systems
crashed down and replaced by these
democratic systems where people had
access to God also said I'd like to have
access to some choice about what my
government's gonna be what it does a
democratic you know capitalism in a way
was kind of a model for that how does
the democratic system survive in a world
where things are happening superfast
where there's a small group of people
with the ability to kind of manipulate
large groups of other people maybe
without their knowing it now how much is
this a threat to the kind of underlying
ideas of the democratic system I mean
it's a hugely super interesting question
I mean I think there is a kind of
parallel and you know American democracy
to what you're talking about in that the
system is evolving in a really
undesigned way I mean we have we have a
system that was designed with the
constitutional system and it was it was
a Republican system which which was
intended to have democracy but with with
constraints and checks and balances and
that's changed pretty rapidly change
slowly over a long time and I think
there was a you know broad social
consensus that making the system more
democratic was a good thing we may be
seeing now with the current political
phenomenon that's transfixing everybody
a way in which an excessively democratic
system a system that's to immediately
reflective of mass will can you know
turn into a kind of majority tyranny
which is the anticipated problem but
it's the evolution and system and I
think where there's a parallel to what
you're talking about is there is a lot
of building first and thinking later
right so with these systems I mean the
idea that security is the afterthought
rather than than the result of a sort of
premeditated design is what is what's
scary about it does this does everything
we're going through in the election I
look different to historically than
other periods we've gone through people
kind of decried the end of American
democratic systems not the I mean not
because it's nasty you know it's it's
been it's been very nasty in the past I
mean I think it does field it does feel
different to me because I think there is
you know what's been exposed is is I
mean we're kind of getting off your
topic a little bit onto mine but I think
you know we're seeing a you know kind of
nationalism and a kind of undemocratic
thinking that hasn't been part of our
political discourse I mean you know you
could talk about it just in relation to
violence right I mean what I don't think
we've had a president major Party
presidential candidate before who
applauded violence and thought violence
was a reasonable tactic within the
within the system it's an interesting
historical timing when you go back and
you look at the if you ask yourself the
question why is it that countries like
Spain and Italy and Japan and Germany
ended up with this hyper nationalist
culture and then became kind of fascism
yet a theory of that is that those were
societies hit by the force of the
Industrial Revolution with immature
political and social structures and that
Great Britain and fan France had been
through these revolutions they could it
was hard but they absorb that shock when
it came and could kind of move forward I
think it's a very interesting question
ask yourself which is as this shock of
the information revolution hits any
societies what are the ones that have
been built to kind of ride that wave out
you know politically I think one of
these you know can you take a $0.07 view
of a country and say okay this one has
the networks that are likely to be a
well-liked survive that kind of shock
and this one doesn't there's there's
tremendous risk there I mean in
democratic theory you know the
possibility of immediate direct
democracy you know which is in some ways
an expression of the Jeffersonian idea
trunks was never possible there was no
you couldn't do that in the 18th century
you had to have representative democracy
because there was no way we now have the
possibility of immediate direct
democracy we decided we the the most
Democrats democratic system was one in
which there was a national Paletta site
electronically on every issue the
country confronted you know several
times a day or we could we could make
our decisions that way I think that
would be a very bad idea but we are but
we're developing a lot of habits that
emulate that people in a way what people
do on social media all day long is
express their views they vote on
different things and so there's this way
in which it's sort of happening and I
think that is bleeding into policy you
know I'm very curious about that which
is one things we haven't talked a lot
about a day I I'm also curious about the
AI extension of that which is do we
imagine in future presidential elections
that the candidate says but you're not
just voting for me you're voting for my
AI over here and like who you really
want to answer the phone at 3:00 a.m.
who's AI do you want to answer the phone
at 3:00 a.m. and they're like how many
elections after that at the AIS
themselves actually running for
president you know I'm a much better I
won 5-straight go Championships you
should go with me of course the new job
is in president its gatekeeper yes
except well so should we take something
out look question let's open it up for
question and I think I'm maybe I don't
know if we have microphones out there
but if we don't just please some speak
come to the yeah there's a microphone
back there so walk up the microphone if
you'd like to ask a question and and
just ask one question and make it as to
the point as possible so we can get
quite a few in hi Michael Coble I attend
NYU here and I also work at a data and
analytics company here in New York
called parsley my question is generally
these networks that we're talking about
are all software companies technology
companies both old and new and generally
a lot of these companies have received
venture capital investment and at what
point short term versus long term do you
think that this affects the risk and
probability of the security if a company
receives an investment and the
negotiation is form or a short term
return versus long term how does that
affect kind of the security not
necessarily your specific answer but
just your overall thoughts on that well
I think we know the answer which is that
you know we discover that the the
investment in security is mounting
earlier just so de minimis compared to
the overall architecture and also the
nature of these systems by the way you
know if you if you watch as I did in the
course of reporting out this book these
hacking competitions
and you see these people who you know a
22 year old kid can cut through a Google
Chrome browser that was built by a bunch
of PhDs it's clear those PhDs were not
spending most of their time focusing on
security they were spending most their
time on how do you render images and
graphics and track people as they move
more efficiently so the nature of the
system already is optimized much more
towards other features other than
security and I think we know that the
economic impact of that is investors
want returns I want ya on this question
had a conversation with a prominent
venture capitalist who said in passing
that it was possible to build an
alternate secure internet and it could
be done for maybe 50 million or hundred
million dollars and he had a guy who he
thought could do it and I was like what
are you going to do it because that's
I'm this to be like a very well now the
guy had this idea for him plumbing
involving shoes and he thought it was
more so he sort of put it on the shelf
for the moment which just sort of
perfectly encapsulated everything that
was wrong with Silicon Valley yeah yeah
Jerry Steve eka you you mentioned that
the Industrial Revolution did have an
impact and now networking is having a
major impact I'd like to know what
system you expect after networking to
have a major impact well I mean the real
question is is I mean the obvious one
has to do with artificial intelligence
which is the way in which we and I've
got a lot about this in the book how we
interact with the machines where is the
human in the loop and the speed at which
that is progressing so in 1997 was the
first time a computer an IBM computer
was able to beat a world-class chess
player and the week that happened the
New York Times wrote this piece and it's
very authoritative fashion saying this
is a dramatic thing that's happened but
it's going to be a hundred years before
they can beat a go player it's simply
too complex as we know alphago be the
world champion go player you know four
out of five matches in the last few
weeks so the speed of the development of
AI is just extraordinary and I think we
have so little understanding of it and
the world of people doing AI development
don't really particularly want to be
regulated they just want to move as fast
as they can so that's very much the
world of the future there's got
the book there's an AI there's kind of a
there's two camps of people so there's a
group who the great question in AI is
you build one when is it coming for you
so there's two theories there's a group
called the boxers and the boxers believe
you can put an AI in a box you can
design it in such a way that there's no
problem getting out and then there's a
group they don't have a formal name but
they're either the realists or the
paranoia acts depending on how you
choose to look at it who think no matter
how good a box you build it's going to
get out right imagine that a being that
was a million times less intelligent
that you tried to keep you imprisoned in
your home you probably would find a way
eventually to get out so these guys the
famous line of the people who don't
believe the boxers is that connecting an
AI to any system at all it's sort of
like leaving MacGyver in a room of
discarded tools and saying like oh just
stay here for a while we'll be back to
get you so this this really is the
interesting question the world of AI
which is we're building these things all
the incentive structures are to make
them fast and smart and amazing and all
you have to do every the seeds of that
are being planted in the papers today or
if you read yesterday Google i/o it's
filled with chat pods AI engine same
thing would happen in the Facebook
conference that they had and I think
that's what you're seeing is that
everybody they do believe that the next
great platform is an AI platform that it
may be the first platform in the world
to have five billion people on it nobody
wants to miss the economic opportunity
associated with that and so that world
of people is kind of driving us in that
direction at the moment with very little
supervision and also there's very few
people could actually understand that
it's a tiny group of people who
understand that could it be grumpy old
man from aspire when my role in this
battle from Pai I always object to the
the example of AI finally beating a
human at chess because it strikes me
that is a example that is precisely
analogous to a car beating a human and
running a race so yes it by 1910 an
automobile could outpace a human being
but the whole point of races is that
there's supposed to be between human
beings so it's like it's apples and
oranges well of course of course the
computer can beat us that's the right
posture I happen to have dinner in beige
with the chairmanship of the world go
association rotates between a Japanese a
Korean in a Chinese so I had dinner the
week after Alfa going with the current
chairman who was who's Chinese and I
said am I kind of you know semi snarky
way don't you need to add a fourth thing
to that rotation that it goes from a
Chinese or Japanese degree into a
machine and then kind of works its way
around and what he said was he's like
actually know what's so exciting about
this is that it chain it's going to
change the human against human game
they're essentially not that interested
right now the computer is going to beat
us it's just like beating a car but
actually racing is you know maybe gets
more interesting as a result but isn't
there a huge gap in social and ethical
thinking around technology I mean a lot
of you know and given what's happened
with cybersecurity we've been talking
about artificial intelligence is that
much more terrified in medicine and
genetics thinking about ethics and
social implications is deeply integrated
into the process in the for-profit
technology world it's not seems like a
huge afterthought absolutely I mean I
you know the last chapter of the book
begins with Plato and ends with AI I
mean I really am trying to say like okay
you've got it and this is one of my
points about the 7th sense which is it's
not just become more technical it is how
do we educate ourselves really in these
kind of core humanistic values which are
going to allow us to answer these
questions and can we get out there and
do it fast enough because the incentive
to just kind of keep building these
things faster and faster and you go you
read there's a number of very
interesting philosophers Nick Bostrom
and other people who are working on the
problems of AI and ethics and it's just
it's what you would expect it to be for
something that's five years old it's
very very primitive and so that work of
I think is I sort of trying to say that
the nature of the age were moving into
means everything has to be a reassess
the way we run our economy is the way we
communicate the way we have our
political structures and this is very
exciting work but just at the moment you
don't feel like anybody's really doing
it let's take a few more questions yeah
I'm wondering about Ponzi schemes of
course they don't work after 20 or 30
states because they are hierarchical but
you see anything like Ponzi blow up in
networks interesting I mean one of the
interesting questions and it gets back
to this
of how we choose to design the networks
so networks are not in different network
designs have different vulnerabilities
associated with them so there this one
of the kind of canonical moments in the
history of the internet with this great
engineer from Rand named Paul bran had
been asked to solve this problem of how
is it that American military bases can
communicate with the White House after a
nuclear attack and so he came to New
York City downtown where there was this
giant AT&T switching center that was in
charge of linking all the military bases
together because the design of that
network the topology of that network was
there was one switching Center so all
you had to do was hit that switching
Center and the entire American military
would have been you know it blinded
really at a moment where they needed to
respond and so brands great instinct was
to say okay let's create this
distributed system which became the
internet where messages could spread and
they have their own addressing protocols
and it was not vulnerable to a single
attack news equation about the
ponzi-scheme thing is one of the things
about our current system is it does
allow for very rapid propagation of
errors and mistakes anywhere in the
system so the problem of this highly
concentrated Center where everybody goes
to Google everybody go to Facebook if
there's a virus that can escape out of
Facebook's or something called code
injection which kind of can go right
into your into the heart of your machine
everybody who connects there is going to
be influenced as a result so that that
is a it's again why it's not quite right
to say it's networks versus hierarchies
that structure has a hierarchical
element to it so it's not quite a Ponzi
scheme but it is it is a dangerous way
in which things spread
whether or not investment internet
companies is a Ponzi scheme is a whole
nother comfortable we're about to find
out yeah hi there Eric Neil
I'm wondering has the 7th sense' always
existed and if so or if not so which is
it just that we finally have a tool or a
platform where we're able to express it
it's able to be compared and compete and
then possibly is if there's one that
becomes dominant will there be an eighth
sense or does it keep going my next book
uh the I so if you read the book you'll
see I start the book actually with a
kind of a tour of ancient Chinese
philosophy when I moved to China I was
lucky enough to make a lot of very good
friends one of them introduced me to
Chinese Zen master who would tell you
that the seventh sense has always
existed that it is this feeling for the
interconnectedness of all things and
that what's happened in our modern lives
is we've become too atomistic we're all
about the individual that the great
blessing of the Enlightenment which
liberated all of us so that where you
were born who your parents were didn't
determine your future what determine
your future were your own kind of dreams
and ideas did that made us way too
focused on ourselves and so he would
tell you the seven steps did always
exist and that that it isn't getting
back to that and you try especially also
always has this kind of it's all it's
very backwards looking to some degree
and that that set of values I think
informs a lot of the thinking there and
what interesting things is how would you
actually cultivate it is not simply by
mastering neural networks it is by
getting back to these these deeper
instincts yeah hi I'm Jani Hao I'm a
former journalist turned former analyst
at linkedin here in new york so at the
World Economic Forum and LinkedIn talks
about this a lot they discussed the
fourth Industrial Revolution that could
displace like 5 to 10 million jobs in
the next number of years so now there's
a big push to get everyone ready for
that and learn how to code in addition
to whatever you do and which would be an
impetus to get you to work for a company
or work directly for the companies that
leverage these few social networks that
can power whatever is you can learn now
how do you how do you think that sorry
how to word this um so how do you think
that we can make that like a good push
to technology and not push all the power
and to just leveraging these few handful
of social networks or companies second I
I don't know the answer I mean what
things I'm always struck by is the way
in which people are so confident that
the jobs are going to take care of
themselves people like oh people that
during the Industrial Revolution the
machines were gonna wipe out all the
jobs then we found new jobs for people
as you know nurses and you know
journalists and all these other sorts of
things
and I I don't know that for sure I mean
I'm not confident that
that in an economic structure of a kind
of competitive labor force in a world
where so much work is done by machines
continues to be the model and then you
really get into these core questions
which is about what how does a life
lived what is the role of labor in and
in a life I do think that the fourth
Industrial Revolution strikes me as too
narrow a concept I don't think this is
an industrial revolution I really do
think it is it's actually something
completely new and I think if you look
at industrial terms you may miss a lot
of a location of where the change is
really happening yeah hi this is Tom
from Social Symphony I'm thinking more
about the micro part right now about
connection and we've talked a lot about
the system and the network what about
people in the sense that we mentioned
billions of networks for Facebook and
Twitter etc most of those a lot of them
on Facebook are about friends and about
being nice in a sense you're not trying
to be a negative person in these milk
billions of people so I'm just wondering
about connection and this billions of
people now are about how they find
compassion how they find gratitude in
the connections nodding the web moving
away from a lot of the security and the
issues that we talk a lot of macro kind
of ideas how about the people not my
user you literally wrote the book on
this originally I mean I I yeah exactly
you know in thinking about how to humans
distribute information and friendship
and these other things on networks I
have you seen any sort of changes in
that dynamic as the world becomes more
information eyes or connected first of
all that was very artfully handed off to
that's the $0.08 prison coming in 2018
not affected I well that's the million
dollar question do social networks are
they simply energizing and accentuating
art sorry electronic networks are they
accentuating and energizing of existing
patterns of social interaction are they
creating new ones and I suspect I always
thought it was the former but like most
things I once believed I think it's now
the latter but I don't know whether I
don't think that there is this I'm more
interested in many of these cases in the
in the response to the trend and the
trend itself so the more and more that
we rely on electronic networks to manage
our social interactions the more
privileged the old-school face-to-face
encounter becomes in a certain way you
know is now that it used to be that I
talk to everyone on the phone now I talk
to almost no one on the phone but when I
do have a phone conversation it's
incredibly kind of moving and touching
by virtue Allah by virtue of its novelty
so I wonder whether that you know the we
will kind of in this paradoxical way you
know we'll go back to vinyl on many
different levels you know if I was this
person was within the valley last we
could built this one of these giant
things said to me something variously
said you know the great insight that he
had had was that it that the building
these social networks would be about
mapping the real connections into the
virtual world and so many people when
they started in the early kind of
internet revolution were like I'm going
to make an entire community of you know
people like cats and that's going to be
a giant business for me and it turned
out it was these seven friends and ten
days at Facebook that Exelero is about
pulling those ones in what is really
interesting now is I think you do see
this kind of hunger for getting back to
old school make by the way a shameless
plug for my wife's business which is
very you know which Nora's very into
crafting and it's disappearing crafter
runs a business which brings together
people what's interesting about is they
have these craft jams that they do and
it's not like there's some pre-existing
Network there happens to be a group of
people who would like to be in a sewing
circle and 50 years ago
would've been a sewing circle or a
knitting circle now that's gone and they
use the technology to kind of get
together to form one so it's sort of
it's kind of pushing it from the virtual
back into the real if you were to
believe David Brooks none of us have
anymore
have friends anymore so we're just
sitting at home alone so that we that's
why when I call you you weep alright let
Chris take maybe one or two last
questions yes sir
ape Suleiman technologist in the finance
industry and NYU grad student it seems
to me that networks over time have
developed the ability to create a
protective layer that kind of represents
the the will of the many nodes in the
network that see the benefit of a
network against the the negative effects
that a few nodes could inject and I mean
we could see that in the way we drive
today you see one or two people you know
running a red light but everybody else
obediently you know pauses and stops as
required
we all have unlimited phone minutes but
we don't prank call each other and stuff
like that the financial markets seem to
kind of hit some abs and highs and but
then in general they kind of want the
same thing raise capital benefits
everybody
do you see a an end to this is there a
way or is there a finite limit to our
ability to keep growing our networks
seven billion people yet still develop
these frameworks that kind of protect us
yeah it means also some of these
frameworks are kind of embedded in the
system themselves but they do have and
there's a lot of really fascinating work
being done on amo immunological systems
which is very relevant I talked about
some of this in the book so these
questions of cybersecurity what is it
makes a system resilient what is it that
makes it robust against particular kinds
of channel challenges the problem again
is just the speed now is so fast from
the design perspective if you're
optimizing for speed you're actually
optimizing in some cases to create
accelerants for sort of bad behavior all
the dangerous behavior because those are
the things that spread fastest in a
network so that ability to again to kind
of gate and control what's in or out
turns out to be really really crucial
you know and do you have social
structures that
actually bring out the best in people
right that when they're faced with
crisis do you have that kind of shared
sense of community or shared sense of
values and so it's really interesting is
it's less are the networks can evolve in
certain ways because what really gets
interesting
I make this point in the book like
network scientist is interesting but
it's so primitive today because mostly
we're studying single networks what's
really interesting you understand this
from the financial world is the
interaction of various networks right
it's the air action of the commodities
networks and the networks of people
doing short-term trading and and whether
networks for instance weather
forecasting networks that maybe we have
to have an impact on something so one of
the issues and par the reason again I
sort of end the book with you know with
Plato of all things is this idea that
the network you can't just have a
technological network you need a social
network that serves as to control the
pace of this to stop infections but if
you just built a technological network
there's just no way you can protect
yourself that that self protective
system gets worn off simply by the speed
and the friction of the exchange do we
have maybe one last question okay hello
my name is Nancy and I'm super
fascinated by the concept of how weak
the networks are and we brought up like
the electric grid is one of the the IT
guys like biggest concerns and I
immediately struck me that nobody have
talked about climate change and the fact
that that is what's our biggest threat
against these networks these geek
keeping societies and when like
governments go into these gatekeeping
concepts like how are we going to break
down those walls and come together I'm
one of the biggest threats of all that's
threatening everybody humankind as a
whole and then how can we use like the
topological trends and upticks to all
come together as one network and fight
the overall threat of climate change you
know it's actually there were maybe
three questions I started the book with
and they were all derived from this
issue of why is it today that there are
problems we can see more clearly we
haven't been able to see them in human
history and we can do nothing about them
we can measure climate change name or
you know effectively and accurately than
ever in human history and that to me it
was like I remember watching the two
things really struck my mind one was the
BP oil spill when they sent those HD
cameras down and there was like a
television channel you
watch which was like pollution TV and
you just all day long in HD there it was
and the same thing after Fukushima when
they took these high-speed drones in
that could kind of move in with HD TV
and you could see a reactor meltdown in
real time I was like this is a metaphor
for our age there are all these problems
we can see income inequality climate
change massive immigration waves we see
them with a degree of fidelity
impossible ever before in human history
we can do absolutely nothing about them
I did a footnote about that about why
that's so dangerous is that the more you
see these systems failing the more you
see our leaders failing to deal with
them the more you start to suspect that
there's something really wrong in the
system so this is like an accelerant of
the collapse of the credibility of the
institutions the thing about networks is
when you when you look at them not as a
zero-sum game but as this positive sum
game you understand that everybody in
the system by being connected by green
to the rules of the game is better off
and so getting into that mindset and
developing a kind of position where you
can sort of say we there are these maths
problems these so-called tragedies of
the Commons that affect all of us
that tends to be what real leadership in
foreign policy is like so it used to be
that the goal if you were trying to lead
American foreign policy would be how do
I keep the country from getting invaded
or how do I keep this country from
overrunning some other neighboring
country now the problem because we're
all connected is how do you manage and
create an incentive structure for the
evolution of the entire system and
that's the great foreign policy debate
that's the great international system
debate that we should be having not
these kind of tactical debates because
only when you come at it from that whole
perspective and say there it is the
evolution of the entire network that is
the threat to us not just individual
forces but the network of climate
connections network of economics that
you need to have a system that has more
equitable distribution of wealth if it's
going to be politically sustainable
that's the place you have to begin those
considerations and the network's
actually at the very moment you might
think we have no tools to deal with they
give us all the tools tools to deal with
it so just a matter of kind of
conceptualizing it the right way all
other questions are actually answered in
Josh's book which Jacob had to reach why
it was a pleasure it's incredibly
stimulating and I believe it's for sale
outside and I commend it to all of you
thank you all very much going it thank
you for doing this
thank you